was ist das das ist schon mysteriös die
rückseite des mondes ist wohl doch ganz
anders als die vorderseite zu dieser
überraschenden erkenntnis kommt der
chinesische rover youtube zwei der
regionen des mondes erforscht wo sonst
bislang noch niemand war
und das ist nicht die einzige
spektakuläre erkenntnis klicks um
science fiction die gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpassen sie nichts los geht's da
schüttelt kommen im januar des
vergangenen jahres 2009 10 hatte die
chinesische mondsonde chang'e e4 den
mond rover auf der rückseite des mondes
abgesetzt die ersten spuren im mond sand
hatte der rover youtube zwei dann schon
zwölf stunden nach der landung
hinterlassen seitdem hat er sich etwa
370 meter bewegt zunächst klingt das
echt wenig doch dafür gibt es einen
grund der over läuft mit solarenergie
und die sonne scheint ihn nur alle zwei
wochen an das liegt an der sehr
langsamen eigenen rotation des mondes
die ganze mission ist super spannend
denn es werden regionen des erdtrabanten
erforscht die vorher noch nie irgend
jemand zu gesicht bekommen hat jetzt der
erste große erfolg des mond rovers an
der landesstelle im sogenannten von
karmann krater ist er auf einem meter
dicke sand und staub schicht gestoßen
und die ist wirklich nicht ohne
insgesamt zwölf meter dick ist die
schicht des materials feinem sand als
staub ende tatsächlich ähnelt dieser
mondstaub den kunden die bereits der us
amerikanischen apollo mission und der
sowjetischen luna mission auf der
vorderseite des mondes gelungen waren
das ist somit eine brandneue erkenntnis
denn zuvor wusste man nicht inwiefern
sich die oberfläche des mondes in
verschiedener regionen ähnlich ist oder
nicht zudem ist diese entdeckung äußerst
spektakulär denn das material stammt aus
dem mondinneren und kann somit wohl
spannende erkenntnisse zur geologischen
entstehung des erdtrabanten liefern die
radardaten von youtube 2 machten es dem
chinesischen forschungsteam möglich sehr
detailliert unter die oberfläche der
mond rückseite zu schauen und dann gibt
es noch mehr überraschungen dem
forschungsteam zufolge gelang es dem
radar jada haase 2 so die deutsche
übersetzung von youtube 2 insgesamt 40
meter in die tiefe zu blicken die
analyse zeigt dass die oberste schicht
etwa zwölf meter dick ist und aus fein
gemahlenem regolith besteht das ist der
feine sehr
scharfkantige mondstaub der sich sogar
durch raumanzüge und die feinsten
schlitze dort fressen kann darunter eine
ebenfalls etwa zwölf meter dicke schicht
aus steinen und riesigen felsen und in
den entsprechenden zwischenräumen dünne
lagen eines feinen materials der
aktuellen studie zufolge folgt dann eine
region in der sich fein ist und grobes
material abwechseln dabei konnten die
radler aufnahmen nicht einmal den boden
des kraters nachweisen was bedeutet dass
dieser noch tiefer liegen muss
meteoriteneinschläge haben nach ansicht
der fachleute zu den mindestens 40 meter
dicken auflage geführt diese haben wohl
im laufe der mond geschichte gigantische
mengen an gestein aus der mondoberfläche
geschlagen und dann verteilt fachleute
hatten zuvor jedenfalls nicht damit
gerechnet dass die oberste
oberflächenschicht der mond rückseite so
dick ist aufgrund der beobachtungen die
man durch die apollo mondlandungen
gewonnen hatte war die wissenschafts
community gerade mal von einem viertel
also drei metern ausgegangen dazu wie
schon bei der an der studie beteiligt
war bislang wissen wir dass die
beschaffenheit unter der oberfläche an
der landesstelle von channel 4 also auf
der rückseite des mondes sehr
kompliziert ist unsere beobachtungen
weisen darauf hin dass die geologischen
beschaffenheit der vorder und rückseite
des mondes völlig unterschiedlich sind
das chinesische forschungsteam ist
optimistisch dass youtube 2 bei der
erforschung der mond rückseite weitere
spektakuläre erkenntnisse liefern wird
denn die radarmessung des luna penne
trading nada codes lpa übertreffen die
der dritten mondsonde chang'e 3 dazu
heißt es in der studie
diese arbeit zeigt dass der umfassende
einsatz des lpr ein neues licht auf das
verständnis der geologischen entwicklung
der rückseite des mondes werfen könnte
und sie hat ja noch mehr geschafft erste
pflanzen wachsen auf dem mond anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren klick zum
science fiction bis dann bleibt dran